I want to talk second quarantine with
someone so we're to bring jenny zigrino
in I need some tips going into this
round - not excited about it but let's
do it
very funny she's been on coding multiple
types she's got great sets please
welcome the very funny jenny zigrino
jenny hi thank you so much for doing
this show Lasky's update what do you
what do you say to people when they ask
how are you doing because it's like it's
a very loaded question now I think that
you know the first time around was like
a lot of motivation and like it's gonna
be great we're gonna get out of this on
top number one now I'm waiting for the
Civil War but in the meantime also you
know writing and exploring myself and
things and you know just um
traveling reading kovat as much as I
can't to speed up hurt immunity I heard
that's actually working really well
you've been you've been traveling you
running a plane I was watching your
stories and it was like a plane what is
that experience right now I had a whole
row to myself it was great everything
came in a bad and it was the best I've
ever been honestly we travel a lot for
stand-up so you're always in like a
middle seat or whatever's the cheapest
seat to get wherever we are but now it's
a little nice / absolutely terrifying so
you're you have the whole row to
yourself the whole row to myself all the
snacks come in a bag they always come in
a bag are people literally are you a bag
full of water and snacks oh so
everything's together so it's just one
thing yeah okay Otten flights before
people just throwing you loose Eminem's
got it well looking around for that one
person who's not wearing a mask we're
all looking yeah it was there any he did
it no are you able to breathe in the
mass for the entirety of the flight yeah
you have to wear it the whole time
reports are so eerie they're so weird
and quiet everything's closed very eerie
and weird
but it's good to be back it's good to be
home
I was a Minnesota so they weren't second
quarantine but now we're doing our
second quarantine I'm gonna do it right
this time roses
Minnesota's like they're okay they're in
a second quarantine now they're still in
their first quarantine yeah it's
confusing where we are on what
quarantine does I don't think they know
that it exists because there are a lot
of people that wear masks
yikes it does sound oddly tempting
though it's just like you you have to
travel so much for this job when this
was still an art form and the fact of
like a quiet airport row to yourself
because most of the flights are just
like way too loud businessmen having
conversations at 6:00 a.m. trying to get
Alan to approve the account not anymore
you could literally just go to LAX get a
plane go your destination and then from
there just fly back just because you
want some like peace and quiet and some
free snacks that's great so how are you
how are you handling the second second
quarantine so I feel like there are some
things that like I'm gonna do that
people can do to make second quarantine
better so like first thing is I'm not
gonna be like lazy and just loungewear
and just whatever let that prime makeup
ieave I got a new quarantine glasses
I'll show you my knee pointing glasses
Oh debut wild crazy Jenny right here no
one can make fun of you when you're in
your own house it's just my wild glasses
and then it's okay so I've also started
it was like came to be a better cook so
like I moved and I got this really nice
new kitchen that I can just cook in
that's why I have some pans
you rude [ __ ] I did for us at
the beginning for your pants so also get
a hobby my hobby now so I sell vintage
clothing so those are my mannequins very
cool well to like make income and a
hobby and it keeps your mind like
awesome kind of like what's going on in
the world and how things aren't safe I
got this Brandi a big living room you
can see you got like a gallery wall and
like all this cool stuff so wait what
was that
what there's like someone is that some
of your going to what's the game yeah
well I put up all my pictures
yeah no that's great that's great was
that is there someone there with you oh
oh you mean that
oh yeah would it that's like a is that a
Trader Joe's employee okay
look I wanted to save this one for last
so ha being is important you know fine
getting your finances but I think the
most important thing to do during the
second quarantine is you know what you
gotta find a friend
I was alone the whole way okay is this
it's like a joke this is the view
did you really kidnap someone okay I'm
sorry
wow this is uh okay first show sorry sir
are you okay I've been here a while I
used to just have a mustache and short
hair
isn't it the beard is cute I think it's
cute sometimes he gets like little
crumbs in it like crackers and like dog
food okay
Manek he looks really scared okay what's
your name Dave Jenny what okay honestly
I'm a little taken aback here this this
is incredibly illegal it seems really
scared are you saying we're looking for
you Dave the chances are slim I live
with 12 other people not okay um Jenny I
just I don't really know what to say but
I you Dave and I we do a lot of fun
things together sometimes you go for
walks sometimes I let him like swim in
the bathtub
very cute we like sometimes they'll
stack two shelves for me perfect every
day perfectly stacked shelves he makes
me a little tight samples of food if I
don't want the whole thing
and then sometimes he just rings the
bell for no reason it's so weird that
he's get so that's a call for help it's
part of our sustainability for usable
head bag initiative here at Jennings
yeah reusable I don't weigh stuff okay
um uh yeah I'm not gonna tell you how to
live your life I get that everyone's
going through a really rough time but I
you gotta let him go this is this is in
it's bananas is insane no you know shame
on you shame on you right now you know
what you got to quarantine with someone
you had someone there when you're scared
and you were feeling like the world is
gonna crush you you had someone to talk
to I didn't anybody okay I like
thousands if not millions of Americans
who don't have anyone to quarantine with
imagine that that loneliness it is so
intense like not be able to touch
someone for like weeks touch grapeshot
cookie and your dad's real proud of you
wait harder than your sisters sometimes
you just want that he knows your dad you
know what I'm gonna say this right now
you should be really ashamed because we
pay these people $12 an hour to risk
their lives for us right day we get
benefits and free plantain chips on
Thursdays my point is is that I just
saving him I'm saving him from the
capitalistic death grip you find
yourself in because you want to get some
trader giotto's [ __ ] portobello
mushroom sauce pomplamoose lasagna
that's exactly what I buy but that's
beside the point I just think I would
feel I would just feel more way more
comfortable if we're putting this out
there live show if Dave just decided if
he wanted to stay here early because it
sounds like it kind of a thing going but
I I mean we should just let him decide
Jen you have to agree on that Dave you
are
ready to go but remember I do have
central air and it is such a wave right
now so what do you think Dave I heard
what you said about how hard it is to
find somebody and we also struggle on
let me just say oh my god
limping did you bobble him oh my god oh
my god okay so well she's gonna chase
him with the way to small net that was
that was that was jenny zigrino you can
see her obviously on Conan she has her
SATs online Comedy Central and the six
o'clock news tonight